if you believe that time goes in a
forward sequence at least in our
universe or within our understanding of
our universe then there's a little
problem with the timing of when Donald
Trump's June Donald Trump juniors lawyer
started getting paid Donald Trump jr.
now has a lawyer who's been saying all
sorts of wacky and zany things in
defense of his client around his meeting
with the Russian lawyer and the Russian
lobbyists in Trump Tower this is a
meeting that we now know he attended
with Jared Kushner and Paul Manafort and
a translator and a member of some family
that wanted to set it up and Rob
Goldstone able to party this is a major
major a group of people that was in this
meeting and this is now an individual in
Donald Trump jr. who's being represented
by the Law Offices of Alan Theodore Foss
great that's who's representing him the
problem around the timing is that Donald
Trump's re-election campaign started
paying this attorney for his work
representing Donald Trump jr. two weeks
before the recent scandal around this
meeting so there's actually four
problems that I've identified with this
or red flags you tell me which is the
worst Pat number one it's harder to
believe that this meeting was a total
non-story
if you hired a guy to defend Trump jr.
two weeks the scandal broke unless he
was hired for some other issue related
to Trump Russia which would also be bad
since Trump jr. wasn't even publicly at
the center of that two weeks ago that's
problem number one problem number two
it's odd that the re-election campaign
of Trump is making these payments our
donors aware when they donate to the
campaign for Donald Trump's re-election
that the money at least part of it is
being used not to help Donald Trump's
reelection chances but for lawyers for
Trump's kid who doesn't even have an
official role in the administration
number three this is an attorney Alan
Theodore Foss who specializes in
white-collar criminal defense not
political law not election law and that
circles back to the question of why was
he hired two weeks before this scandal
broke unless there's way more
potentially criminal activity that he's
representing Donald Trump jr. about and
number four what message
does this send to other White House
staffers who were told you may want to
lawyer up but we're not paying for it
you're on your own but Trump's son who's
not even part of the administration is
getting a lawyer paid for by the
re-election committee of Donald Trump
which is the headline Allen futher Fox
is connected to Mafia family a young New
York or he's represented three or four
mafia organized crime families yep and
you know I get it you're a lawyer you
have to pick some specialty that's your
line of work you can't really get them
at Adam for that it's unclear what
eventual tea is telling that he's now
representing the Trump family oh
absolutely and yeah I don't know what
the big headline is right it could be
that everyone involved knew that this
was a major issue long before it went
public it could be that Trump jr. could
be facing criminal charges it could be
the defrauding of re-election donors to
Trump's re-election campaign who are
being targeted by email requesting
donate to Trump's reelection to help
fight fake news and all this other
garbage and then the money is going for
a lawyer for Don Jr and it also could be
the immorality of wrapping up who knows
how many White House staffers in the
scandal and then leaving them to pay for
their own lawyers while your own donors
are covering expensive lawyers for your
kids and by the way there's one other
scandal brewing here Lachlan Marquis is
the White House reporter for The Daily
Beast he got his hands on a tax document
which I'll put up on the screen for you
which shows a payment to the Trump
corporation for $90,000 on the last day
of June they were paid for legal
consulting breaking news the Trump
Organization is not a law firm
so if Trump's reelection campaign has
cut a $90,000 check to Trump's business
for legal consulting that means one of
two things
it's either straight-up money laundering
they're saying it's really GLE
consulting and it's not or they are
giving 90 grand to the Trump
organization so that the Trump
Organization can then give that 90 grand
to a lawyer for legal services which is
another form of money laundering meaning
you're raising money under the pretext
of being for Trump's re-election and
then it is being given to the Trump
Organization
to pay for lawyers for things that have
nothing to do with re-election I can
only hope that Robert Muller can parse
all of this and determine to quote
Donald Trump what the hell is going on
discuss this with us on our reddit
discussion forum david pakman.com slash
our IDI vit today's episode of the david
pakman show is made possible in part by
Warby Parker eyeglasses Warby Parker
recently did the right thing and ditched
advertising on right-wing conspiracy
website Breitbart
pulling their ads off and you can get
the free five-day home Tryon from Warby
Parker check out their glasses I use
them when I'm not wearing contact lenses
I started with the free at-home trial
they send you five pairs of glasses you
see which ones you like you send them
back and whichever one you pick they
will put your prescription into I like
this because I can actually show the
glasses to other people and not have to
just decide on the spot like in an
eyeglass store the eyeglass industry is
controlled by very few corporations that
keep the prices very very high even over
$300 for prescription glasses with Warby
Parker they start at just 95 bucks mine
cost that including lenses and for every
pair sold they give a pair to someone in
need so to try the five pairs and
support the David Pakman show go to
Warby Parker trial comm /t DPS